yeah we love a surprise hollywood
coupling a source confirms sweetie
bradley cooper and huma abedin are
dating i just want to make sure we give
people what they want so what's the
story with these two let's take a look
et's insider has all the details about
the new romance
our source says quote the couple has
been quiet about their relationship and
has avoided being seen in public they
wanted to get to know one another more
before everyone chimed in once they
found out of course huma is no stranger
to the public guy
i have been the invisible person behind
the primary people in my life she's
currently hillary clinton's chief of
staff following years of working closely
with the former secretary of state and
our source explains quote the couple has
a lot in common and have enjoyed their
time together it's going really well so
it means a lot to us
but how these two get together well it's
been reported that vogue editor-in-chief
anna wintour a longtime friend of pumas
made the introduction and they even
attended the mad gala together but
walked separately
you can even see bradley trailing behind
her and check out humma's instagram
caption on fashion's biggest night quote
remembering what it's like to be
feeling loved she may also remember what
it's like to be in a high-profile
relationship
anthony's made some horrible mistakes
both before he resides in congress and
after puma is the ex of disgraced new
york congressman anthony weiner he
resigned in 2011 after tweeting a lewd
photo and then lying about it this was
followed by several other sexting
scandals involving anthony i couldn't
see that he was completely
disintegrating and we just went into our
corners puma is in the midst of
finalizing their divorce which she filed
back in 2017. she and anthony's share 10
year old son jordan hulma documented
their relationship in her best-selling
memoir both and a life in many worlds
and it was just announced the book will
be adapted into a tv series
i don't know
with slumdog millionaires frida pinto
playing huma
as for bradley he's faring better with
his ex irina shake he and the model
split in 2019 after four years together
they share five-year-old daughter leah
last year irena made a surprise
appearance at the premiere of bradley's
movie nightmare alley the actor gave et
his reaction to irina's show of support
we were very happy to see your family
arena here celebrating you tonight it's
very special yeah
and how about this sweet reaction irina
gave e.t at the met gala that same year
and we we all collectively have loved
seeing how you and bradley have become
incredible co-hangers thank you
[Music]